who's really in control Oh your phone is
freaking Oh your phone a free damn
what's up everyone my name is Pippa and
my son is being scorched ah go away I'm
trying to record what is this did I say
my son is being squished that's what I
meant yes today we're reviewing I'm 14
and this is Dee one of my favorite
subreddits actually because that
everyone can shamefully admit that
they've been this person at least once
in their life
oh god no not the cartoons boomers
favorites question how much did it all
cost answer never forget the sacrifice
of those brave Americans who are ground
up and made into hotdogs I'm 14 and this
is deep really makes you think we live
in a society Mickey Mouse oh my god has
so many friend requests but the real
mouse has no friends what does that even
mean well if you were 14 and deep you
would understand mr. Jamal poor rats
can't even get followings haha gets
motivated by a quote upload C's
subreddit R I'm 14 and this is deep this
photographer removes phones from his
images and the results are a disturbing
reality check I too think it would be
different if we were staring into our
empty palms and not an incredibly
complex device which gives us access to
almost all the information in the world
and can be used to communicate with
other people do you think that's what
they're doing in this picture I'm 14 and
this is not deep enough oh my god this
should be the new face of this subreddit
Billy a leash
she's broken the song title is so clever
what it probably would have taken me
three years fourth when he likes though
I love how the title says she's broken
says he's okay
what I didn't even notice that oh the
son must be giving me extra powers
kids getting annoying go away it's right
in my eyes why did I say to sit down for
once no matter how good the person you
are
you're evil in someone's story oh my god
I want to make it their joke but I am
banned from making those and that says a
lot about society I have an even smaller
wireless device that gives me access to
thousands of books and movies it's a
library card Oh God there needs to be a
Boomer subreddit dedicated to these
cartoons boomers loved cartoons more
than anything if you see a cartoon in
this style you know it's gonna be
something about how kids are dumb do you
think that your attitude towards smart
phones might be an extension of your
fears that you along with your items and
the leaves of yesteryear will become
obsolete that rather than simply
embracing both can change and age your
avoidance and decrying of advancing
technology will mask your slowly
depleting dude Oh get ready doom boomers
sumer bloomer that was Dave that was
second date I broke my light now all
right son took over son it's my new line
that is deep that's just a lot of by
society boomer comics I kind of want to
see that's a thing I love these music
short chain has changed a lot like how
well for starters singers would actually
stink well oh I see what did I mean
they're criticizing like heavy metal
what this is rapping back in my day they
would go the road the wind so other guy
I agree that's Liping think those are
broken web site no matter how many times
you click the pictures nothing happens
it's so cringe kids are so dumb they
don't know what the book is ah yes the
classic weird looked at so when printed
out the bunch of tweets and then they
added extra characters to all the words
all right I call it book they says all
day to be fair though I think I read
somewhere that statistics for reading is
lower it is decreasing
so it's like they're not wrong and it's
the exact same thing I said I think I
saw something about like Zoomers can't
use power tools or something knight-like
that millennial diets apparently have
terrible DIY skills and half of them
don't I own a step ladder or a cordless
drill that fixed the light
apparently 50% of millennial dads don't
own a cordless drill that's deep that's
pathetic all right I want to call this
drill yes stepladder Frick yeah I do say
the screwdrivers of course why are you
gonna ask someone else to do it for you
[ __ ] I've actually never changed a car
wheel but they never broken either so
reset a trip circuit breaker what do
they do
I need help flicking this lever is that
what it is this became a whole tangent
but man that's hilarious
hey can you help me press this button
for me I wonder why that is because now
we have informations to do all these
things you could just google and figure
it out yourself
right if anything Millennials should be
more equipped to do anything than anyone
jumpstart a dead car Barry I've done
this you literally just look up the
tutorial unblock a toilet or sink open
this stuck pickle jar you think oh is
this satire I can't tell
Millennials soy dad's moving on all
right I guess we're not moving on cuz
this is what the subreddit is this is
something that died out around 2021
because too many people were getting
offended by it
I'm starting to realize I'm a more of a
boomer okay I'm hey is he wrong oh god
I'm agreeing with this subreddit is
centering this is not epic I get that
it's not funny oh god I'm going through
a weird self-reflecting trip here and I
don't know what I feel about it could
you not be posted for five minutes
Joker 2019 book that is having more than
two friends equals bad the
no you don't understand it's about the
meaningfulness of your friends it
doesn't matter how many friends you have
maybe they're just not visiting that day
phone to make wife die this is so sad
the phone killed his wife can't believe
it okay so they're not I get it now
my Boomer brain understands this summary
it clearly ain't sunder gonna change
right I haven't changed other people
change I don't change they're not
criticizing the message they're just
criticizing the poorly execution right
uh why can't you be normal
why could you be interesting oh I wish I
was quirky and love skulls and had blue
dyed hair that would be so interesting
girls with blonde hair can never be
interesting everyone knows this there's
Jaden again random person I don't know
who you are
Jaden me either whoa this is so deep
Berenice young read more books and older
generation research find what that is
not the statistics I've heard
Millennials find 83% of the under 30s
read at least one book a year compared
to 79 of their elders brah that's funny
water nine kilometer h2o 50 meters this
says society such an example this is
basically the equivalent of the Jimmy
Neutron sodium meme have you seen that
actually it's sodium chloride just a
little sodium chloride actually dude
it's salt no dude you said sodium
chloride yes it's the same assault but
you could have just said salt instead
everyone in this town knows you're a boy
genius dude you don't need to say overly
large words to sound more intelligent
the batteries that nobody cares how
smart you are is that thing I want
simplistic objects by their scientific
name ironically makes you seem less
intelligent more pompous I know you're
smart enough to be better than this bra
there's an even better one of this one
let me see if I can mine it oh wow this
mean be popping though this is I decide
table salt which in addition to sodium
chloride contains
taking agents and potassium iodate I
don't know how to say that in English
which is added to prevent iodine
deficiency so not only are you being
overly pretentious by insisting on using
scientific terminology for everyday
items you are factually wrong
your arrogance if you're down for your
annoyingly I save her music I save her
photos I save her videos because she
saved life important extremely deep work
smart not hard what the heck is this I
ordered a cube Society I miss you I miss
our neurotically posted by my classmate
what does this mean he's getting cut mom
why do the best people die when you're
in the garden which flowers do you pick
the most beautiful ones
Dave criticizing how addicted we are to
social media
I'll take the Google Translate pill
please or the Google Docs pill I cannot
stop making Google sheets someone stop
me 1995 2005 2010 2011 2012 2015 1
monitor fa9 monitors you are taking it
too far oh god I have too many modern
thoughts I will interact with society
man I wonder if there's actually a fair
point because the elder generation
always complains about the the younger
generation that's just been a thing
that's never gonna change but I wonder
if there's a concern that the older
generation has had that was actually
valid and actually did bad
I wonder what's an example of that
instapage speed 14 year old so sad when
I die I want my heart donated to NASA so
they can finally see what a black hole
looks like deep I felt that I felt that
here go NASA ok so he has an apple tree
and he makes it to ask for pear this is
so deep if you're truly bass you would
understand that all apple trees are bad
because apples are sensational pleasures
that will all lead to suffering this is
truly been deep found this on a
fortnight video that's how you know it's
gotta be good girl as soon as I can
boy will you ever leave me girl no
you're a crazy boy do you love me girl
yes a lot boy have you ever cheated on
me girl no never
boy will you ever kiss me girl every
chance I can get boy will you ever hit
me girl boy can I trust you girl yes boy
babe now read it backwards oh babe yes
can I trust you
definitely not really ever hit me every
chance I get oh god will you ever kiss
me no never
we are achieving yes a lot oh my god
girl bad boy girl I knew it I knew it
we are truly getting deeper into this
sub ready
I want the knock yet but society will
let me
you do realize nah can't make smart boy
just buy a Nokia no one cares this
should be posted in with a Chinese
person someone from Hong Kong I want an
iPhone but I'm forced to buy a huawei
remember when you point a finger at
someone there are three more pointing
back at you no flipping way there that's
true and then one is pointing to this
side what does that mean what is this
the D really makes you think
remember when you're pointing at someone
you're burning calories so it's good to
judge people calm the storm that rages
inside of me whoa whoa go see it talk
that's funny deep oh man I can't believe
on the first day yes I made it my first
day in class woo the school years over
son you missed it
oh because he was a snail oh my god let
me just tell you something about this
final scene i sat through this whole
movie thoroughly enjoyed every last
a bit of it I even made a running motion
when the first two gifts happen what
when the movie finished my boyfriend was
very very quiet and it looked a little
sad I was very confused because it was a
fantastic movie he turned to me and
asked is that supposed to represent how
our education system doesn't make enough
for mentally monsters University then I
thought I don't know what's Cringer the
fact that the boyfriend did this well
the fact that the girlfriend posed in
this that's beautiful make you cringe
babies please more material huge
SuperDuper deep stay on the right path
even if you have to walk alone that's
the left path what I never thought of
that day poor people buy watches that
are 980 dollars poor rich $6,000 phone
well phone is that I mean my boomer
since this is tingling again and had all
these kids before this huh if they
worked for it and made their money I'm
like yeah cool good for you old pirate
to you but you know they haven't you
know is their parents that paid for it
I'm not on board with all of these I'm
just gonna say it every time I open my
eyes I can see what take your age
subtract two then add two how does that
even work how does he know that if you
can't swim and don't swim this is like
the book I wrote many many years ago
this book loves you shout out I was
supposed to be a parody be nice to
people maybe one day they'll be rich
this is so devious yeah I need I need to
make it like a review of my book I have
not read that in years I hope you enjoy
it but don't try and eat it the lasagna
version will be released in the near
future
this book was co-written by Edgar that's
funny I make I make funny haha yeah
shout out to
the book this book loves to you I still
get royalties so thank you guys a glass
is called glass because it is made from
blacks my mind has truly expanded itself
bad basically summarize this entire
subreddit ah yes a comic book I'm
sending you an article about the
importance of bonding with their
children cool not now but we're reading
about being good parents
if only they had books if only they had
books about reading about parent I'm 14
and this is deep I want a mouse I want
the fish I want the milk I want to
change the world my final message
goodbye
[Music]
2009 2019 that kids this age a day in
ten years that's incredible this truly
says a lot about our society viruses too
deep for you viruses humanity in space
society you wanna have something
actually since the universe is expanding
even if okay let's say we invent AI and
we can live forever with AI or whatever
we we have some sort of cosmic children
right AI that is smarter than humans or
likewise so even if we are even if time
wise humanity will go on forever since
the universe expanding at such a rate
that at this point we will never be able
to catch up on it you can only travel as
fast as the speed of light even if we a
have infinite time and B we will invent
the light speed travel we will still not
be able to explore the entire galaxy
there will still be places completely
away from us that was a I I just think
that's cool if swearing is immature why
is it referred as adult language Dave
Dave
sorry sorry boy I'm deep and this is
sodium chloride oh it would seem i h2o
has run out I bet you don't know what
that means
stinky Zoomers this is why there are no
Bigfoot sightings if anything this
should be the opposite cuz now literally
everyone has a camera right everyone in
the world carries a camera with them and
every single day of their life you'd
think if something paranormal happened
people would know about it right people
would have taken a photo of it by now my
friend who dropped out of college posted
this oh geez
the right position oh god I feel bad
imagine dropping out of college
Oh God and posting the pencils as well
Oh God employing like oh this is a yes
this is actually hand drawn I know it
looks hyper-realistic but as you can see
with the pencils here it is actually a
sketch that's the worst part of this may
I have a plastic bag already inside I
mean again yeah by 2050 the oceans could
have more plastic than fish that's
alarming to me call me a Boomer but know
the difference don't be with someone who
hurts you and slaps a bandaid on you on
your wound and calls it love be with
someone who changes and improves himself
to love and protect you I don't
understand why they need to be with a
cactus what did the balloon have popped
after the first pic baddest deep that is
deep bruh
yeah how do you put band-aids it would
have just died right away Oh pump
there's a pump gamers there's a pump I
saw it I got it I'm deep the pressure
society puts on men to be a square yes
the age difference cats used to enjoy
themselves actually went outside to play
now my cat is just sitting on his iPhone
texting ashes tears before you tears
during you tears after you brah why are
you collecting your tears
that's how Hector frickin wee
bruh went to the moon took five photos
went to the bathroom took 105 photos I
mean it is kind of like why you need
goddamnit I'm getting too old to review
the subject if you didn't see my hoodie
today it says we live in a society I got
it because of the message behind it and
how dark society is to this day the
double meaning of the meme that's
beautiful again I'm on the side of the
cartoon school is just trying to make
you think a certain way they don't teach
you about free thinking if the Sims is
only fun with cheap codes what does that
say about capitalism yeah what does that
say about capitalism Matt please
continue yeah right Sims gets old really
quick with cheat codes it's more fun to
play legit I think it says that
sometimes it's fun to cheat that a
salary is the bribe they give you to
forget your dreams oh no one's stopping
you how about this say no to the salary
how about that this is Christ I think
every prisoner should be able to vote
because we all live in a prison called
society society there's a lot of society
happy to go over here Dave see I told
you they would have noticed us because
they're all on the bugs I remember when
people started criticizing it it was
like everyone in the subway now they're
just staring down on their phones like
yeah because before it was boring no one
would talk to each other anyway and you
don't have to wait at the time now you
can entertain yourself with this amazing
device it's like yeah small talk still
exists okay yeah it hasn't gone away
police why are you here someone I am
being a booth I am being a Bose police
what's your name
someone mother earth police who are you
mother earth humans one like equals ten
trees to save the earth one like equals
ten trees Wow
at least 300 trees were saved that is
awesome our plan to raid area 51 our
plan to save the environment this is a
lot about society I mean what is the
plan to save the environment like I
always hear just people whine about it I
think that's why people are so turned
off about it it's become the new vegan
thing if people actually talked about
like veganism not in a way of shaming
people and just saying oh actually it's
really good for the environment not to
eat cow me so many more people would
actually be on board instead of how dare
you there is a way to save the
environment I I realized I recorded this
video a while ago but now mr. Bies has
released his video with the goal to
plant
20 million trees epic and he's asking
youtubers for help to collaborate on
this I'm happy of course to take part of
it I'm gonna make a donation now I'm
also gonna make a video promoting it but
I felt like it fit for me to mention it
at least cuz everyone's asking me about
it and I think it's a really cool
project so check out the link in
description please go donate it's a
great cost for the environment ethic
less whining more epic action epically
okay finish the video Felix yes because
it's impossible to be both intelligent
and athletic
you just can't I mean I realize I'm too
much of a boomer for this I'm too old
for this subreddit guys I'm sorry
well I hope you guys enjoy it anyway
it's much like if you deta really
appreciate it and as always no not as
always oh I remember there's the thing I
needed to tell you guys it's kind of
deep though so prepare yourself have a
great day that's right
you thought I was gonna plug my merge no
I just say have an awesome day
never judge your book by its cover
because that is by the March haha
tricked you dummy never trust anyone
that's deep well you haven't tried to
personal a turd since me after 50
million our troops match
oh yeah now just now it's still relevant
just down a bit